>>Richard Gingras: Well, good afternoon.
Thank you for joining us here in Mountain
View and elsewhere on the VCs and, and for
the audience who will eventually see on, on
YouTube as well.
Very pleased to have Lewis Lapham with us
today.
Let me share a couple of thoughts as we get
into this conversation.
Personally, as a, as a, as a technologist
for some 30 years now, I've long been fascinated
not only by the technological, the impact
of the technological change on media, but
also by our own inclination to believe that
our times are entirely unique.
And of course to some degree our times are
unique.
But that's not only the case.
Often there are common themes across time
that are fascinating and often extremely informative.
In reading Future, the magazine that you have
in front of you this weekend, I was amused
for instance by Plato's conveyance of, of
Socrates' view that the invention of writing
was not a great potion for remembering, that
the marketers of the day were saying it was,
but a tool that would introduce forgetfulness
into the souls of those who learn it; a tool
that would provide students with the appearance
of wisdom, but not with its reality.
Or how, for instance, the Swiss scientist,
Konrad Gessner, raised the alarm about the
effects of information overload and its confusing
and harmful effects on the mind.
The interesting thing was that was in 1565
and his warnings refer to the flood of information
unleashed by the printing press, common themes.
Today we grapple with how the internet has
disrupted the business models of print publications,
but forget for instance that the period of
great near-monopolistic success of newspapers
was really limited to a 40-year period and
triggered largely by the introduction of television
and the subsequent winnowing of three to four
newspaper towns down to one.
It's for those reasons that, that I find the
editorial model of Lapham's Quarterly to be
so fascinating.
Because it looks at a single issue, a single
theme, a single subject, and exposes how that
subject was considered across time.
So if you read this issue of, of, about the
future, you will read Plato, you'll read Roy,
Ray Kurzweil, you'd read Gandhi, you read
Philip K. Dick.
So let's talk to Lewis Lapham.
It's not an overstatement to call the gentleman
at my right here a legend in American literature
and journalism.
His leadership of Harper's Magazine for nearly
30 years and guided it through its richest
period of analysis of our politics and our
culture.
Beyond his editorial leadership, I think it's
important to note that Lewis is a profoundly
talented writer and anyone who simply reads
the introduction to this issue will see that
quite clearly, and a keen observer of our
life, our times, and the ideas that evolve
within that.
As Bill Moyers put it, "Lewis Lapham speaks
the truth to power and wealth in each issue
of America's oldest political journal in the
essays he writes, in the articles he publishes,
he opens the veins on issues like class, power
and politics."
So thank you very much, Lewis, for joining
us today.
>>Lewis Lapham: Thank you, Richard.
[applause]
>>Lewis Lapham: Thank you for that handsome
introduction.
>>Richard Gingras: Well, I only speak the
truth, Lewis.
So why don't we start actually, given Lapham's
Quarterly.
What was your inspiration for starting it
in the first place?
>>Lewis Lapham: Well I started out in life
wanting to become an historian and I went
to graduate school for one year at Cambridge
University in England after I graduated from
Yale and found out very quickly that I was
not cut out to be a scholar.
I didn't have the patience for footnotes.
I had a passion for history and I would listen
to stories about everything and anything.
Talleyrand's mistresses, Kaiser Wilhelm's
uniforms, giant ants standing watch over the
treasure of Peru, the Carthaginian wars, but
I, I was not a true scholar, so I became a
journalist.
And I came to San Francisco, where I was born
and raised in San Francisco, and, and nearby
here in Menlo Park, and the, went to work
as a newspaper reporter in 1957 for the San
Francisco Examiner and then gradually went
to the New York Herald Tribune, went from
the newspaper to the magazine, the Saturday
Evening Post and Life, and then to Harper's
Magazine in the 70s and so I'm old enough
to have seen a number of severe changes.
I mean when I first came to New York in 1960,
there were seven newspapers in the city.
And the Life and the Saturday Evening Post
were the major media of the 60s.
But by the end of the 60s they'd been supplanted
by television and so I was there both for
the collapse of the Saturday Evening Post
and the collapse of Life magazine.
And now you see the kind of what and then
there's the introduction into the New York
Times in the 1970s of the op-ed page, so that
what in the 1950s would have been a 5,000
word article by say the Secretary of War or
an aspiring president of the United States
to be published in Harper's Magazine or the
Atlantic by the end of the 1970s that had
become a 750-word op-ed page piece in the
Times or in the Wall Street Journal.
And then of course you, you, you get the,
the arrival of the internet in the 1980s and
you see the recasting not only of the newspapers,
but also of network television so that the
forms are continually evolving and I'm again
old enough to have seen a number of those
changes and so I'm not either horrified or
surprised by the move to the internet.
>>Richard Gingras: And so what led you recently
to, to creating Lapham's Quarterly?
>>Lewis Lapham: Well, I'd, I'd been the editor
of Harper's Magazine for 30 years and I found
that journalism can only take you so far,
and that good long form journalism is, is
hard to come by.
There are people that can do it well and they
are rare and precious talents, but there are
not that many of them, and I also noticed
that a lot of journalism was beginning to
repeat itself and also in the 80s it became
much more politicized.
You were either for us or against us, you
were either writing for a neo-conservative
journal or for a liberal journal and they
weren't really talking to each other.
When I first became the editor of Harper's
Magazine in the 70s, I could manage to put
somebody like Irving Kristol and Michael Harrington
in the same issue.
I then believed in something called the marketplace
of ideas, but during the 1980s with the election
of Reagan, the, and what were then known as
the culture wars, journalism became more polemical
and it, you began to see the rise of people
like Rush Limbaugh, who makes an appearance
I think in the 1980, 1983 with the change
of ruling by the FCC.
And so I was becoming increasingly dissatisfied
with journalism, at least as I under, I'm
talking about monthly long form journalism
with literary pretentions.
[laughing] I'm not, I'm not talking about
news clips or, or headlines and I found that
I was reading, more and more I was reading
history, because I was finding in the reading
of history a, a, a substance, a form of narrative
that I could and less opinion.
In other words, so much of journalism was
turning into talking head opinion and it was
a ques, and I was more interested in what
do we know as opposed to what do we think?
And I was finding the answers to that kind
of question in, in works of history.
And I also was getting older and when you
are the editor of Harper's Magazine, what
you would do is you would take 15 manuscripts
home at night and hope to God you could turn
at least one or two of them into something
worth reading.
And I didn't want to spend my time reading
so many badly-written manuscripts and I figured,
here, I wanted to re-read the Thucydides or
Gibbon or Tolstoy or Dickens or Balzac and
get back to the works that had survived the
wreckage of time and the winnowing of bad
translation by reason of the force of expression
and the, and the power of imagination, so.
>>Richard Gingras: So with regard to this
issue, which people have before them right
now on the future, were there specific messages
that you had in mind as you assembled that?
Did you know-
>>Lewis Lapham: No.
>>Richard Gingras: when you went into it?
>>Lewis Lapham: Well, I, I just knew that
it was a, I, this quarterly has been going
on for about, it's been going on for four
years, this is the last of volume 4.
And what we do is we take a topic that's more
or less in the news.
In other words, in the spring we, we did one
on work, 'cause the question of unemployment
was in the headlines.
Last summer we did one on food, because food
is a page one story in many different ways,
in terms of the world's natural resources,
in terms of environment, in terms of rising
population as well as in terms of the aesthetics
of, of fine dining.
And we've, we've done issues on medicine and
on money and on war.
And so I, I try to find a subject that is,
has some purchase in the current conversation,
and at the moment, at least in the United
States, there is a good deal of concern about
the future.
It is not what it used to be, and so this
is an approach to the idea of the future over
time as it, as existed.
I mean you can actually look at the future,
you can think of the future as America's first
and best natural resource.
I mean it's, the future is what moves the
merchandise in or you know I will happy birthday
at every point of sale, I will be a new man
or a new woman.
And so that when you're buying the car or
where you're buying the eyebrow pencil, you're
in a way, buying the future.
I mean it's the, it's the, it's the advertising
business.
And much of our consumer society is founded
on the advertising.
So there's that kind of future and then there's
also the dark and apocalyptic future, which
is the one that is used by sometimes the state
at other times by the church to keep the population
in line.
In other words, it was the great source of
power for the Vatican or for the Christian
church through most of its 2000 years, the
fear, the fear, the fear of hell, you know.
And it's also what keeps the money coming
to our military defense complex.
The fear of Russians or the fear of Al-Qaeda
or terrorists behind every bush, and so on,
is what, you know, bids up the prices of the
weapons industries and we have now the market
in fear essentially was what was the was the
main product being sold by the Bush administration
for eight, eight years.
And we now have something like 840,000 people
working for the National Security Agency,
and they are the landest, the largest landholder
in Virginia by far, although most of the facilities
are underground.
[laughing] But the, so yeah, I mean the either
the hope of the future or the fear of the
future are what drives both the America's
politics and its economy.
>>Richard Gingras: I'd like to, let's, let's
go a little bit deeper on that.
I was, I won't quote the whole thing because
you just touched on it here, but, but clearly
post 9/11 as, as you point out, we've, we've,
we've seen the loss of our utopian romance,
our, our sense of the positive future, which
is important because it's our perception of
the future that really affects what we do
in the present in many regards.
>>Lewis Lapham: Well, it's the perception
of the future that is in fact the stock market.
Because when you're buying stock you're buying
the future.
Ninety-seven percent of the dollars in circulation
are invested in the future.
I mean that's, that's what you're buying.
I don't mean to interrupt, I just mean to
confirm your point.
>>Richard Gingras: Yes.
>>Lewis Lapham: Okay.
>>Richard Gingras: Yes, yes and so given that
and given that we've the American psyche was
always about hope, was always about the, the,
the quest to the future, ambition, we could
all do something better, and that has deteriorated
substantially if not nearly completely in
the last decade with the exception of maybe
pockets of innovation.
How do we, how do we switch that?
Is there a, any guidance on how we move our
perception in that regard?
>>Lewis Lapham: Well, it, it, it changes.
I mean, I mean, you're right, I mean the idea
of America is, is a brave new world and Thomas
Paine is talks actually says "America is the
birthday of a new world, full of life, liberty
and the pursuit of happiness."
Those are the promises.
And that's the premise of the constitution,
it's all, the constitution is a tool with
which to plow the ground of one's own invention
of one's self or acquiring of property or
making something of one's self.
I mean, I mean these are the freedoms granted
by the constitution and it's in certainly
in the thought of Jefferson.
We, but again, the future has changed shape
over, over time.
I can remember when the future was rosy and,
and, and bright.
I, I, I, [pause] I, I, I can remember the,
the Kennedy administration.
I can remember the election of, of, of John
Kennedy in 1960, a brave new world, a new
frontier, men on their way to the moon, the
young Kennedy appeared in the guise of the
young Prince Hal inheriting the kingdom from
the aged Uncle Eisenhower and again a sense
of youthful hope and expectation.
And then of course you have and you have the
assassination of Kennedy and that leads to
some of the what follows from that or among
the things that follow are the argument about
the Vietnam war, the reappraisal of the American
government as a tyrannical, lying establishment.
You know you get, you get the on one hand
in the 60s you have you have various visions
of the futures in the 60s.
You have the flower people and the and Woodstock
and the summer of love, and then on the other
hand you have the Chicago Convention of 1968,
the assassination not only of Jack Kennedy,
but also his brother and of Martin Luther
King.
You have the complete transformation of the
Beatles.
[laughing] I was, I spent the, let me see
get the year right, yeah the fall, I'm sorry,
the early winter of 1968 in Rishikesh with
the Beatles.
And the Beatles had just come from the summer
of love in the states and '68 is the here
they are in Rishikesh talking to the Maharishi
and it's the same, at the same time as the
Tet Offensive that is taking place in Vietnam
where it becomes clear that we have lost the
war.
And then followed in that spring of '68 by
the assassinations of Bobby Kennedy and, and
Martin Luther King and then the Chicago riots
in the summer of '68 and the you can see the
turn in, in, in the Beatles' music.
The music that of you know prior to '68 tends
to be have a happy, lilting, hopeful tone
and after '68 it begins, the Beatles break
up very soon after that and the music begins
to turn interior, and ambiguity and melancholy.
There was a very dismal view of the future
at the end of the Nixon administration.
Not only do you have the Vietnam War and the
violence of the civil rights movement, but
you also had the Watergate, you had the revelations
of America's treachery abroad under the guidance
of the CIA in Chile and elsewhere.
And you get a period where the interest rate
by the end of the 1970s, the interest rate
has gone up to whatever, 18%.
Gold is selling for even more money than it's
selling today and there's a feeling of gloom,
which is encapsulated in Carter, who just
talking about American malaise and there's
this feeling of depression and then you have
that followed by the new morning in American
brought by Ronald Reagan from sunny California.
So yeah, the idea of the future is a work
in progress and it changes and it is of course
exactly what drives the stock market.
The stock market is simply a, it, it, about
the values of hope and fear.
>>Richard Gingras: That's an interesting and
keen observation.
I think again we tend to forget that I think
that part of what I take out of that is in
a sense our, our, our views of the future
have typically been more pessimistic than
optimistic.
>>Lewis Lapham: Well, you know, yeah in our,
in our recent history, yes.
>>Richard Gingras: Yeah.
I'd like to take and, and, and torque this
a bit and, and given your decades of experience
in media and, and your first hand witnessing
of media transformation in various instances,
and, and certainly I have to believe your
longer term study of the evolution of media,
certainly we want to talk about the internet.
But before we even go there, I'd be interested
in your insights as to how journalism itself
has transformed over time in approach, in
tone.
For instance today we decry and for good reason
how much of today's mass media landscape is,
is, is so tawdry, but forget that journalism,
though that term wasn't really used then in
the time of Jefferson, was not exactly a paragon
of, of, of truth, ideas and wisdom.
>>Lewis Lapham: Far from it.
The journalism as we know it, at least as
far as I, if I got the story straight, starts
with the Fugger Newsletters in the 16th century
in Augsburg, Germany.
The Fugger Bank was the biggest and most powerful
bank in medieval Germany and it starts as
newsletters from agents in various parts of
the world: letters from Peru about the mines;
letters from Egypt about cotton.
It's all about trade and it's all about money.
That's the first birth of journalism.
And it is today a, which is one of the reasons
why today the probably the biggest and largest
and most successful news organization in New
York is Bloomberg.
Bloomberg is hiring foreign correspondents,
they have 2600 foreign correspondents, all
of them reporting on markets.
I mean if you want to know what real estate
costs 42 miles southeast of Sophia, Bloomberg
will tell you.
And so there is and that is journalism at
its roots.
That's the root of it.
It's also the root of the early journalism
in America.
You have a few newspapers, you're talking
about Jefferson and Adams and the Alien and
Sedition Act in the newspapers of the 1890s
and they are violently partisan.
Accusation, the accusations that are being
leveled by the Federalist's papers at Jefferson
and by the Republican papers at Adams are
would today be considered scandalous and outrageous
beyond belief.
I mean, I mean all of the writers would be
sent home to wash out their mouths with soap.
[laughing] There was nothing they wouldn't
accuse each other of, and, but the, then in
the, in the, in the, those were newspapers
of limited circulation and with a specifically
political purpose.
The major newspapers, I can't remember the
names of them, but they were for the merchants.
They were the kinds of things, enormous broad
sheets as long as four feet across and six
feet long, which would be spread out on coffeehouse
tables in the ports of Boston, New York and
Charleston and again, it's all about trade.
It's about which ships are arriving, which
ships are departing, what cargoes are being
sold, what land is being advertised and so
on.
Then in the 1830s you begin to get the sensationalist
press, the New York Sun comes on and sells
for a penny, where the established merchant
press sold for five or ten cents.
And these are fabulous stories.
I mean they're about scandal, they're about
murders in Five Points in the City of New
York, they're about, you know, it's what Henry
Luce in his memos setting up Time magazine
in 1920 sent a memo to the staff explaining
what Time magazine was about and what it was
about according to Henry Luce was, I quote,
"sex and gru."
By gru he meant gruesome, you know, murder,
train wrecks, kind of along the lines of the
New York Post today.
So the journalism has always played to the
crowd, I mean, and it's played to a market
and it deals in sensation.
And the people who say, well, why is the press
so filled with bad news, why can't they give
us some good news?
And the point, that kind of criticism misses
the point, because the good news is the advertising.
[laughter]
>>Lewis Lapham: The, the, the bad news is
the suckering the, the customers into the
tent so that they can then, you know, in the
first whatever, the top of the hour on the
news is the body bags in Brooklyn and the
terrorists in Libya and the forest fires in
California, and then when you're thoroughly
frightened or then comes on the smiling advertiser.
Obey the law, pay your taxes, and you get
to go to the Virgin Islands on the American
Express card.
And that's the good news and that's what the
press does.
I mean the press you know hustles the bad
news in order to sell the ads.
I mean it's, I don't know if you know the
way a newspaper is made up, but a newspaper
is made up, first, the first thing are the
ads.
I mean you get a, this was true when I was
working for the San Francisco Examiner and
again when I was working for the New York
Herald Tribune.
I mean you get the dummy comes up and all
the ad space is blocked out and the how many
ads have been sold tell you how much copy
you can put in.
I mean the news is, is secondary, subject
to the advertising.
And again what a newspaper is selling, mostly
it's selling itself in its traditional form,
it's not selling itself as a source of information,
it's selling itself as a billboard, that's
its, that's its product and that's where it
makes its money, from the advertising.
So again, the, it's subject to a market force
and always has been.
[cough]
>>Richard Gingras: I want to make sure we
have time for questions, but there's at least
one more I want to get in before we do that
and it's an area that I find particularly
interesting in studying the evolution of media.
It seems that with the introduction of new
media technologies, whether one is talking
about the printing press, or radio, or television,
or the internet itself for that matter, there's
typically a longer lag before the form and
style of the media itself change, understandably.
Radio news, for instance, began with announcers
reading the newspaper to their audiences before
they recognized that a better, a different
writing style, crisper and so on, was more
appropriate for that form and so on and so
forth.
As much as I appreciate long form narrative
journalism, we know from analyses of audiences
and reading habits and so on that people today
have far less patience and are far less inclined
to go to that full length of that 3000 word
article.
I ask you this question because in your history
you, among your achievements have been interesting
innovations in form.
When you returned to Harper's in the 80s,
one of your big innovations there was the
Harper's Index, which for those of you don't
know it was basically this crisp, bullet pointed
list of statistical observations.
There was both knowledge and observation in
those very simple statements.
So do you have any ideas or see opportunities
in the evolution of the forms we use to convey
complex ideas?
>>Lewis Lapham: Yes, I do.
I see a lot of room for that.
I mean I, it was the Harper's Index that,
those of you are familiar with it, but I also
did something called Harper's Readings, which
was like, they were short form things, excerpts
taken from longer passages and from obscure
places from minor journalism, journals or
from foreign newspapers and usually or from
court transcripts or from legal memoranda
of various kinds.
I mean they were found objects and presented
in many of the, in much of the same way that
quite a few of the blogs are now presented
on the internet.
This was before the internet actually.
This was 1983 and the, and then we also had
a form called the Annotation, where we would
take a document, whether it was a hospital
bill or a writ of execution and then spread
it out on, on two pages and then with annotation,
draw out the meaning behind the language or
what the point was and so forth.
And again, the form is constantly evolving
and changing.
I and I think this is true not only with the,
with print, but also with what can be done
online, also what can be done with film or
documentary.
I mean I have a great fondness for documentary
film and I, but I think it can be further
developed and become more of an art form.
The moveable type is invented in 1450 more
or less and for the first 50-60 years, the
reaction from the humanists in Italy and elsewhere
in Europe is one of horror.
It, its, as Richard said at the beginning
of this conversation that the horror expressed
by the established authorities has a way of
sounding the same across time.
I mean he was, you were mentioning somebody
from 1565 and then much of that is true.
Much of it of what was being said you know
with the new type was worthless.
But that's also true of much of what now gets
posted on the internet.
The, your writing for, it's a, much of it
is disposable.
It's language that is meant to be used as
disposable, I mean, you know, it's a customer,
I mean it's a consumer good, it's like Kleenex.
Ok, but, but that's always been true.
And it takes, I mean if you go back and read
the, the list of books that get, I forget
what the major prizes are, the Pulitzer Prize
and so forth, if you go back and look at the
history of those books for fiction over the
last hundred years, you'll be appalled at
how many of them are so bad.
The, the, but we, they weren't thought of
as bad at the time, but they're seen as, they
don't survive because their, the strength
of their thought or expression is not sufficient
to survive the, the test of time so that we
have a different look at them from our perspective.
But the, I'm losing my train of, but no, its,
so you have the moveable type comes in the
late 15th century, but it's another hundred
years before you get to Cervantes, Shakespeare
and Montaigne, all of whom are more or less
contemporary at the end of the 16th century,
who have found a way to use the new tool and,
and, and bring to it art and high form of
expression and I assume that we will be doing
the same kind of thing with whatever language
evolves out of the, out of the technology
that we now have with the internet.
I mean obviously they'll be a drive toward
compression, it, something in the direction,
it'll take twitlet, if you can elevate Twitter
to the, to the form of a Japanese haiku, that's
the kind of thing that, that, or you'll see
it if you're familiar with the Hermann Hesse's
book, The Glass Bead Game, you, you will see
again, a, a, that's like writing a computer
program with not only philosophical ideas,
but also with musical phrase and poetic metaphor.
I mean I would think that anybody at Google
would find an extraordinary groping toward
some of the same kind of thinking in Hesse's
book.
>>Richard Gingras: I'm gonna ask for questions
if someone would like to approach the mic.
>>Lewis Lapham: [coughing]
>>Richard Gingras: I mean to that last point
while someone, while we, while we hunt for
a questioner, if not I'll jump in with one.
But it's interesting that whenever there's
a new medium that allows the propagation of
more information, the first concern is that
that's just gonna yield more junk.
And of course that's true, but it also seems
true that the wheat to chaff ratios over time
stay about the same.
So with the internet, no question, there's
hugely more chaff, but there's also a lot
more wheat.
It might take a little bit more time to find
it, but it's there.
Hugh?
>>male #1/Hugh: Thank you.
These days most major publications live in
a bifurcated state, with an online edition
and a print edition.
Lapham's Quarterly maintains a website.
I was wondering how you think of the two as
separate entities, and more generally, where,
where you see this strange bifurcation going?
>>Lewis Lapham: Well, we, we, our website
is not a replication of, of, of the, the journal.
It, it's its own thing.
It's an allied endeavor in a different form
and there are things we can do on the internet
with juxtaposition, with, we have a one of
the departments is something called déjà
vu, so we will take a news story off you know
within the last month or so either a news
story or photograph and then match it to something
remarkably close from 300, 500, 1000 years
ago and we have set it up as a dissolve, so
that you have the, the first thing you see
is the current image or the current story
and then it dissolves into the, into the historical
record.
We also find it is a way of using, of, of,
of getting contributions from interested readers
who will send further texts and, and, and
supplements.
We're also using it as an audio source and
the not only interviews with some writers
and, and historians, but also a way of getting
at the sound archive.
We have a, in the United States both at the
Smithsonian and the University of Michigan
very voluminous sound archives, so the idea
would be if in the issue itself we have a
speech by Teddy Roosevelt, on the website
you'd, you could hear it.
And the, there are amazing things that can
be done with that, we haven't developed that
yet to the fullest possibility and there's
also the other way of I'm hoping to use it
for documentary film.
The, I made a documentary film a couple of
years ago then it was up for a prize in Amsterdam
and I went to the Amsterdam International
Documentary Film Festival and I stayed in
Amsterdam for three or four days and I was
astonished to see how much documentary film
there is being made all over the world, I
mean, you know, by people in not only Saudi
Arabia and Mongolia, but also in Indonesia
as well as in Russia and the Balkans and so
on and none of this really makes it on to
American TV, because there's no market.
The, the BBC will take maybe 50 of these films
a year for distribution in England, but our,
at least at the moment our television, PBS,
Bravo and so on, History Channel, are not
interested in politics.
I mean it's ok, polar bears and [laughing]
you know, disappearing ice, but they don't
want us to see the political story or the
historical story and some of this, a lot of
this again is not very good, but that's true
of anything.
It's not only true of, I mean there's not
only a lot of junk in the newspa, on the internet,
there's a lot of junk in the bookstores.
There's a lot of junk.
I mean the world is full of junk, but, but
the, but it's also there is you know the,
there's gold, too, and the, and the idea is
to, and the gold usually takes time to appreciate
it or to it takes engagement on the part of
the reader.
In other words, the work of art to me is the
engagement between the, the artist and the
beholder and if they're, and you get a moment
in time really where the person looking at
the painting or the person reading the poem
or the novel or the philosophy tract, is in
the same space at the same, [pause] I don't
know what you call it, the same cloud maybe
as, as, as the person who painted the painting
or the author who wrote the book.
And it is in that joining of human energy
that is the reason that great art survives.
I mean it's, it's miraculous.
And it can happen, I mean it can happen off
any kind of a platform.
But each platform, I would think, would have
a different, something of a different medium.
I can remember coming to New York in 1960
and there were, it was clearly distinct literature
and theater, dance, music, jazz, they were
called in those days the seven lively arts
and they had different audiences, they were
different disciplines, they required different
kinds of skills.
And they were each, they were all valued within
their own terms.
By the end of the 60s you have something called
media.
Media is the word that comes out of Marshall
McLuhan and Understanding Media in 1964.
And by the end of the decade the seven lively
arts had been kind of fused into an amalgam
called media, which is something else, so
that [cough] again it's constantly in flux.
I'll tell you another difficulty with media,
I mean I did a film once that was a history
of American foreign policy in the, in the
20th century and I got to write it as well
as to walk around Hanoi and talk it, but the,
you come up against this kind of problem,
you come up against, I was given either, I
can't remember whether it was 73 words in
42 seconds or 42 words in 73 seconds in which
to explain the origin of World War II.
And the voice over had to connect the still
footage of the Munich conference in, in, in
1938 with the news footage of the German Stukas
bombing Warsaw in 1939 and there you see,
that's a problem in form.
I'm not saying it can't be done.
I don't think it, I did it, but I don't think
I did it very well.
But in order to do that well, you have to
evolve a kind of a language that is again
closer to poetry than it is, than it is to
prose and maybe that is certainly the direction
over the last hundred years has been towards
shorter and shorter and shorter.
I mean if you go back and read Harper's Magazine
in 1850, everything was 10,000 words and very
small print and then so that's clearly a direction.
Visual is another, you know, but the thing
is there's so much room to experiment and,
and to fool around, I mean it, it is a, I
would think an exciting prospect to try to
invent new forms and within the new form still
have the density and the intensity of something
worth thinking about.
>>Richard Gingras: Lewis, I, I, I have to
thank you.
Your perspectives are both refreshing and
inspiring no matter how difficult some of
the times might be.
I don't know if we have time for a, I think
we don't, as much as I would love to.
I also want to close with definitely go to
that go to link, get your free subscription
and if you can afford it, buy another subscription
and give it to a friend.
>>Lewis Lapham: Yes.
>>Richard Gingras: Forty-nine dollars a year.
It's a great buy.
It's hours of entertainment and knowledge.
I can't imagine a cheaper source of entertainment
and knowledge.
So go buy one.
Now.
But again, I, it's, it's, it's been an absolute
pleasure, indeed an honor
>>Lewis Lapham: Richard, thank you.
>>Richard Gingras: and I look forward to continuing
the conversation.
>>Lewis Lapham: Thank you very much.
>>Richard Gingras: Thank you.
>>Lewis Lapham: Thanks.
[applause]